哇,我昨天看到有人分享這篇貼文
然後說是一個平常專門在分享
財經觀點的財經網美發的
我一開始完全不信誒
我想說這篇貼文就是一個很常見的
一個搞不清楚遊戲規則的投資菜籍
然後他在看到長榮發18塊利息
但是又跌得這麼慘的時候
就是那種滿臉困惑的心情
就是他
那你可以看到他說
長榮為什麼跌成這樣
我也不懂啊
一張100塊不到一個月就可以拿18塊股息
然後他覺得這樣就是一個月賺18塊
然後他就把它乘以12
說是一年賺216%
然後說法人現在買什麼東西更好
沒有啊
怎麼可能會比這個更好
唯一就是除非你走投無路了
你才有可能賣長榮
然後最後講個俏皮話
哇靠,這樣3000多人按讚
實在太猛了
首先就是
中間他說
月曆率18%
一年就是200多%
這已經不只是沒有基本的財經知識
也不懂交易的遊戲規則
就是這是連數學跟基本邏輯都完全沒有
就算他認為一個月賺18%
也不是一年賺200多%
那如果他這樣算的話
那如果他是說這個
出席的前一天買
那一天賺18塊
哇那他這樣的話是不是就是當作是一年賺18x365
這樣是多少呢?
哇那他一年賺6500多塊也就是6500多%的投資報酬率
他應該可以非常輕易地發現自己的這個算法荒謬到不行
就是不只是數學跟基本的邏輯都完全沒有
然後再來就是交易的遊戲規則他也完全不知道嘛
就是18塊的那個股息其實是從你自己的錢拿給你自己
所以出席當天你的資產不一定會增加18%
如果當天的股價下跌的話
你當天的資產甚至有可能是減少的
例如說長榮今天是減5%嘛
那你那一天可能資產就是減5%
就是
不過這個是
這個
其實出席也是很常見的事情啊
只是他也搞不清楚
然後
就是
他說
法人現在買什麼東西更好
沒有啊
好那
這個
股票的話我們就是要個股參考投信
我們看一下投信最近的動向
投信最近
12345678910
投信最近已經連續10天賣鈔了
然後他說
法人怎麼可能會賣這個股票
沒有比這個更好的標的
欸法人在幹嘛
好啊他可能不會用看盤軟體
但是
投信外資的買賣超這個google就可以看到吧
然後就算他不知道要在哪裡查
他也可以問一下別人嘛
就是
這這個這個這個這個這個這個這個都是超級容易找到的知識
然後為什麼股票一直下跌
就是
下跌的股票
趨勢會有延續性
所以通常會繼續下跌嘛
那如果他是要分享財經觀點的話
那他可以說
啊因為6月16這個這個FED的FOMC公布升息三碼
所以全球的股市就因此暴跌
然後這個這個這個升息三碼是因為前面的CPI公布超高超級嚴重的通貨膨脹
那所以這個這個沒辦法
美言廚之號加劇他的這個升息
用更鷹派的做法
欸這些都是在網路上超級容易查到的知識
而且應該其他的財經新聞也是講到爆吧
這都已經6月16到現在都已經過一個禮拜了
他連去抄別人的財經觀點都沒有辦法
然後就把自己內心的那個菜季完全不知道發生什麼事的真實想法
FB貼文貼出來
這真的超扯的
我們還是還是講一下人家的優點嘛
人家人家這個經營社群的能力真的很厲害好不好
3000多個讚欸
欸這樣一篇完全錯誤的貼文可以3000多個讚
我自己發的那些FB的交易實戰復盤
都只有幾千的觀看
欸那些交易實戰復盤
我自己覺得啊
你直接把它下載拿去賣給別人
當付費課程
真的都會有人買
然後他這個
完全不知道在幹嘛
吻3000多個讚欸
像前面這一根
看到就想到那天這個操作真的很省
我是打期貨
當天賣在169塊
然後
30口長榮期賣掉
當天28口
142.5買回來
好不好
這個YouTube前面也有
去看一下好不好
然後
我們也講一下這個
基本的交易邏輯啦
就是
順勢交易好不好
不要因為一個股票一直下跌
然後你就在那邊算那個殖利率
算那個本益比
然後發現哇
因為股票一直下跌的時候
殖利率跟本益比就會一直上升嘛
然後你就會覺得
哇
太棒了
現在趕快去買
好不好
這是完全錯的
股票一直在下跌的時候
就
開始跌
打空單
好不好
就是
這一天嘛
6月16
凌晨2點
FOMC
公佈升級3碼
打空單
好嗎
那看你要打到哪裡
比如說100
這個整數關卡回補
或是你去比照前面的前滴
這些都可以
但是不會是打多單
好嗎
這就跟
我在FB發了很多次文
說不要
跌破600塊的台積電一直買
因為那時候也是很多財經網紅
發說這個價值投資啊
跌破600塊的台積電就無腦
一直買
你就一直存股
然後他們也沒有提到要停損
因為他們那種存股方式
就是沒有在停損嘛
這絕對是完全錯誤的做法
如果你真的很喜歡這家公司
你可以在它開始上漲的時候
去買它
好嗎
就是在趨勢開始反轉後進場
這個
這個邏輯我已經跟大家講過很多次了
然後我在
這個
就是FONC公布升級兩碼還是三碼的前面這個禮拜五
我就已經
這個6月10號之前我在群組提醒大家
我今天把我手上全部持有的股票全部都賣掉了
我手上已經完全沒有多單了
那你們也應該要減少你們的多單
或者是完全出清你們的多單
如果你真的很喜歡這家公司
你可以在這個FONC公布只升級兩碼
那全球股市可能開始暴漲的時候
這個地方你就把你的股票都買回來嘛
那後面有可能就是遲到一段暴漲
如果升級兩碼的話
那升級三碼的話
當然就不要買回來嘛
然後你更機機一點你就可以打空單嘛
這個才是標準的做法嘛
就是當然這是比較中階的交易邏輯
但也沒有很難
好嗎
好啦
最後我們還是這個
跟大家分享一些正面正確的姿勢啦
好不好
這個
這種錯誤的姿勢的FBTLN
完全錯誤的
也可以三千多個讚
我們還是分享一些正確的姿勢啦
好不好
好啦就這樣啦